si vous êtes ici c'est peut-être que
vous faites partie des 50% des français
qui ont du mal à dormir il vous est
difficile de vous détendre avant de vous
coucher vous cogiter en pensant à votre
journée à votre emploi du temps du
lendemain
il existe pourtant une solution
naturelle qui a fait ses preuves depuis
des générations
l'utilisation des plantes le fit aux
nuits en sachet à infuser un mélange
innovant de mélatonine l'hormone
naturelle du sommeil et de cinq plants
vous aide à vous endormir et bien dormir
alors ne pensez plus à rien et profiter
de cette séance de relaxation en
partenariat avec fit aux nuits le figaro
présente inspiration un podcast de
benjamin lubinski psy hypnothérapeute il
youtuber imaginer la semaine dernière ge
accueilli mathieu tordeur dans mon
podcast inspiration c'est un jeune
explorateur il a 29 ans et lors de sa
27e année il a décidé est allé au pôle
sud mais sans aide en transportant 100
kg de nourriture d'équipement des
rallyes il a réussi en un peu plus de 50
jours à parvenir au pivot de la terre en
affrontant bien sûr un froid tout à fait
polaire c'est le cas de le dire mais
surtout imaginer ce qu'il faut pour
pouvoir lutter contre le froid lutter
contre la douleur lutter contre ces
angoisses et rumination ce qu'il a fait
c'est que il avait un but à but précis
atteindre le pôle sud et cela lui a
permis de mettre de côté tout ça toute
la douleur tout l'envoi sous des
ruminations mais aussi toute la solitude
alors bien sûr pour travailler sur vos
douleurs je ne vais pas vous inviter à
tenter la même expérience ni même tenté
d'aller groenland ou en islande
on va faire quelque chose beaucoup plus
confortable que l'hypnose est l'hypnose
ce qu'on va faire ensemble va vous
permettre de faire d'une pierre trois
coups
d'abord elle va vous permettre de
diminuer votre douleur
c'est important ou votre stress parce
que pour travailler sur la douleur et le
stress on peut travailler de la même
manière dont qu'on peut faire
d'une pierre deux coups et puis on peut
me faire d'une pierre trois coups et
l'utilisé également pour s'endormir donc
si vous voulez l'utiliser pour gérer
votre douleur ou votre stress à un
moment je vous invitera à sortir de
l'état hypnotique et si vous voulez
dormir évidemment non tu n'es pas
content et laissez vous porter dans le
sommeil de l'hypnose et puis ensuite
dans le sommeil de la nuit
alors comme d'habitude je vais vous
inviter à vous installer confortablement
à prendre la position que vous préférez
pour la nuit mais surtout comme il
s'agit de diminuer les douleurs de
prendre ce qu'on appelle l opposition la
posture analgésiques terre celle qui
vous fait le moins mal donc vraiment
prenez le temps s'il faut bouger un peu
une épaule un bras les jambes qu'elle
est un oreiller pour que ce soit plus
facile vraiment prenez le temps il faut
que vous soyez le plus confortable et le
moins douloureux possible
et puis si c'est simplement le stress
qui vous amène à faire
cette séance est bien installé vous
confortablement simplement le plus
confortablement possible parce que le
fait d'avoir un corps qui est dans le
confort permet d'entrer encore plus
facilement en transe et ensuite son
dernière facilement donc c'est bon ok
parfait on va se lancer
j'ai demandé de commencer un fixe et un
point peu importe lequel
et oui déjà se centrer sur l'extérieur
même si c'est quelque chose de très
léger comme de fixe à un point cela
permet de commencer à se mettre
légèrement hors du stress ou encore de
la douleur tout simplement parce que
l'attention focalisée ailleurs et alors
évidemment ce sont des variations qui
sont légères au départ mais avec
l'hypnose vous allez pouvoir avoir ce
que l'on appelle une dissociation tard
vous allez pouvoir m la douleur et le
stress d'un côté pour pouvoir vous
rentrez dans un confort en été nautique
de plus en plus profond est évident
qu'en recommençons cette séance vous
allez acquérir un été nautique de plus
en plus profond ce qui veut dire de plus
en plus un analgésique de plus en plus
relaxant de plus en plus efficaces donc
ça demande un petit peu d'entraînement
mais dès la première fois vous arriverez
déjà vous endormir et à laisser de côté
la douleur et le stress donc commencer
simplement par fixer ce point est il
faut qu'on a vraiment tout le temps du
monde que rien ne presse le moment vous
rentre en transes le moment où les
douleurs le stress auront disparu on a
vraiment tout le temps c'est un
processus
je suis content et de sakal peu importe
le moment où les yeux se fermeront ce
sera le signal que vous êtes en transe
et puis de toute façon l'état hypnotique
de plus en plus profonde plus en plus
relaxant de plus en plus un analgésique
antidouleur et plus vous répéterez comme
je vous le disais tout à l'heure plus
arrivera vite et surtout vous n'avez
aucun effort à faire pour une fois il
s'agit pas décidé de tenir absolument
contre la douleur contre ses angoisses
juste vous laisser porter comme si
j'étais simplement un ami qui se soucier
de vous venez vous parlez s'enquérir de
votre vie vous parlez aussi simplement
de la sienne il n'ya pas d'effort
particulier à faire parce que l'hypnose
va s'installer tout seul en vous et
c'est encore ce que l'on appelle un
processus dissociatifs un fixer votre
attention sur ce point puis les moments
où votre esprit décrochera n'entendra
pas certain certains mots certaines
phrases oubliera finalement et son corps
et sa pensée consciente pour voguer un
peu à l'extérieur c'est très bien c'est
ce que l'on recherche
5 et puis voyez donc simplement le fait
de fixer ce point c'est le point de
départ c'est lequel le dire vas
l'hypnose qui encore qui est une sorte
d'abstraction de l'extérieur et cela se
fait tout doucement et rien que le fait
de se poser confortablement dans cette
posture qui vous permettent de moins
souffrir de laisser la souffrance effacé
à son rythme eh bien rien que cela aussi
de se laisser porter par ma voix est
d'observer des chats la respiration qui
elle même presque tout seul commence à
ralentir devenir plus lente plus douce
plus régulière et bien c'est cela le
début du processus d'intériorisation qui
va l'hypnose en qui est l'hypnose
pourrait-on dire
vous savez comme il est facile de noeuds
ce centre est une sensation comme le
contact de l'air contre le visage aux
contres les mains ou de se centrer sur
le poids des bras des jambes ou bien de
se centrer sur ma voix le timbre de ma
voix même un peu plus lent un peu plus
calme assure fois que l'esprit centre et
ailleurs le stress diminuer la
souffrance s'oublie tout simplement à
son rythme évidemment comme on est dans
une sorte progression comme en ligne à
se presser pour se débarrasser de tout
cela cela va être comme si l'on allait
effacer progressivement les soucis le
stress la douleur comment oublier un
sorte de tableau noir à l'école dont on
effacerait la craie
au fur et à mesure en se disant bien
qu'à un moment ou un autre
tout le tableau sera effacée et puis
simplement donc le fait de se porter sur
m'avoir centré sur différentes
sensations ça peut être aussi par
exemple le contact d'où des draps le
contact dude et des vêtements
le son de ma voix votre propre
respiration n'en parlais tout à l'heure
et bien cela crée ce processus
d'intériorisation et c'est pour cela que
la respiration donc s'approfondit tout
seul mais pour donner une inspiration
supplémentaires aussi parce que la
respiration permet de gérer et le stress
et la douleur
prenez deux inspirations profondes comme
pour vous éloigner de toutes les
difficultés de toutes les douleurs
de vrais inspiration comme ça et puis on
laisse les pensées s'accrocher se
décrocher aller à leur rythme les
sensations si les pensées qui se forment
se déforme forme d'autres formes
et puis l'on peut sentir au travers de
cette respiration devenu plus profond
que lente plus gagnent et bien un air
frais qui semble se diffuser comme ça
dans les poumons j'aime bien cette image
de racines de cas mais pourquoi pas
plutôt imaginé sorte de vent frais que
vous inspirez qui passe par les narines
puis se diffusant les poumons et cette
fraîcheur pourrait envahir à son rythme
tout le corps et apporter une sorte de
de fraîcheur 12 qui contrasterait avec
les chaleurs du lit de l'autre côté
quelque sorte l'intérieur du corps
ferait un peu engourdie par le calme de
cette respiration le reste du corps
bien au chaud est protégé par la couette
letra où la couverture peu importe
et puis il suffit d'observer le corps
qui se détend les muscles qui se
détournent cela apporte aussi une sorte
de relâchement de soulagement de la
douleur qui peut s'éloigner un peu comme
si la douleur était un chien le sait que
avec ce relâchement musculaire vous
laissiez le chien s'éloigner avec une
laisse de plus en plus loin il n'est pas
encore temps de l'oublier mais bientôt
vous pourrez l'oublier et passer à
quelque chose d'autre à quelque chose de
bien plus confortable et peu importe à
quelle distance est encore la douleur
puisque nous avons tout le temps et
toute l'intelligence de l'hypnose et
tout ce qu'apporte la répétition des
techniques qui pratique à l'autohypnose
permet d'avoir une diminution de la
douleur quand on fait l'hypnose même
pour un sujet autre que la douleur eh
bien il centre de la douleur dans le
cerveau voient leur activité
/ de effacées en quelques sortes
eh ben on peut aller bien sûr encore
plus loin c'est pour ça que l'hypnose
est utilisé pour effacer la douleur dans
les centres antidouleur mais aussi pour
faire des opérations à ce qu'on appelle
des hypno anesthésie ou d'autres
approches comme ça qui sont de plus en
plus fréquentes et permet d'utiliser de
moins en moins de médicaments même si
est tout à fait normal d'utiliser des
médicaments avec
l'hypnose à tout ce qui efface la
douleur est bon à prendre et de cette
manière c'est un peu comme si en
apportant un soulagement au corps et par
l'hypnose et par une vie de plus en plus
agréable que vous allez pouvoir
reconstruire mais aussi grâce aux
médicaments antidouleur que vous prenez
certainement et bien le corps et
apprenaient avoir la mémoire le souvenir
la sensation d'un corps de plus en plus
agréable à son rythme bien sûr
alors on peut sentir aussi les les
sensations qui évoluent et la
respiration qui devient plus lourde plus
profondes
mais en même temps cet air frais léger
c'est comme s'il permettait à l'esprit
un petit peu de de planer ou en tout cas
de s'alléger
vous savez comme quand on est dans un
train par exemple qu'on regarde le
paysage est consommé à penser autre
chose ou lorsque l'on est face à
quelqu'un qui est particulièrement
ennuyeux et coeur se prend à penser à
tout à fait autre chose ou même ce
moment juste avant le sommeil qu'on
appelle l'etape la logique où on pense à
toutes sortes de choses font plus aucun
lien de logique mais c'est un petit peu
comme si on sortait de son corps et
c'est en cela que la respiration apporte
un allègement de l'esprit tandis que le
corps lui en contrebas lui peut
s'alourdir donner un peu plus lourd
encore les bras les jambes à son rythme
bien sûr il vous pouvez sentir son poids
qui s'imprime agréablement sur le ligne
le lit qui est tout alourdi de score
lourd et le lit qui pèse de tout son
poids sur le sol orques l'esprit lui
peut s'imaginer un peu plus léger
peut-être
voler un petit peu au dessus de vous
peut-être même vers le plafond ou un peu
plus loin on peut s'imaginer déjà
observons sa maison au loin de son
immeuble où déjà se mettra à rêver de
certaines choses parfois complètement
différente de ce que je peux vous
décrire et c'est ça aussi ce qu'il y a
un peu de magique dans l'inconscience
est que dans l'ip nocilla un terrain où
il peut reprendre les années créé dans
votre corps et les expériences et les
sensations dont vous avez besoin donc
peut-être celle d'un esprit qui s'envole
et qui va d'ailleurs faire un voyage
agréable parce que le corps lui
justement en contrebas de l'autre côté
s'alourdit donc le lilou relie
solidement craie sur le sol le sol lourd
du lit du corps et puis le sol lourd
dullier du corps qui pèse de tout son
poids sur la fondation de cet immeuble
de cette maison et cette maison très
très lourde à la fois de son propre
poids mais aussi d' de ses fondations de
deux sauts sol mais aussi de ses
fondations de ce sol de ce lit de ce
corps tout cela tout à fait lourd pèse
lourdement sur la terre et la terre est
lourdement secrète en tout cas fortement
inscrite dans le système solaire le
système solaire avec une grande force
ancré dans la voie lactée il mais lui
non plus loin la voie lactée tout mast
l'univers en tout cas la voie lactée
ancré dans toute la masse de l'univers
pesant de tout son pouvoir mais où je ne
sais pas peut-être au travers du temps
ce à dire que l'univers est ancré dans
le temps et le coton un peu plus long
pour un peu plus lent en créant vous
pour que votre esprit s'allège et que
vous entriez encore plus en transe 3
et pour une fois j'aimerais voir contre
une autre histoire par une histoire de
dorment va plutôt l'histoire d'un
psychiatre d'un thérapeute hors du
commun qui s'appelait milton erickson et
qui s'était donné comme presque comme
mission d'aider à soulager la douleur
avec l'hypnose mitraille sur bien
d'autres sujets mais c'était vraiment un
sujet qu'il affectionnait c'est pour ça
qu'il a écrit un livre passionnant
dessus et c'est grâce à lui qu'on a les
techniques qu'on utilise aujourd'hui
pour soulager les douleurs et aussi pour
travailler en hypnose avec n'importe qui
parce que désormais avec cette manière
cette approche n'importe qui peut pas
prendre faire de l'hypnose est donc à
gérer sa douleur
peu importe le niveau du départ c'est
quelque chose qui s'apprend par la
répétition et il avait des manières
intéressante de dire une fois il parlait
comme ça quelqu'un qui était en train
d'entrer en transe et il lui dit
imaginer qu'un tigre rentrer dans votre
chambre
est ce que vous auriez encore mal ou est
ce que vous seriez déjà en train de fuir
et d'oublier votre douleur presque sur
le lit est la personne la découvre et
bizarrement que sa douleur avait déjà
diminué mais c'était certainement mais
c'était certainement l'effet de la
suggestion nautique et la même manière
avec quelqu'un qui était un peu
réfractaires avec l'hypnose il avait
fait ce que l'on appelle de l'hypnose
conversationnelle c'est-à-dire grand
discutant avec lui tout simplement de
tout rien est un sujet dont on va parler
dans un instant et bien il avait créé un
état de ti comme le vôtre qui se
développe de plus en plus il lui
racontait une histoire de jardinage cela
peut sembler étonnant presque un peu en
tuant cela peut sembler étonnant presque
un peu ennuyeuse peut-être pour ça que
vous entrez toujours un peu plus en
transe et devant cette personne qui elle
aussi était en train de rentrer en
transe de plus en plus est
fouad oublier son corps est d'être prêt
par une sorte d'états différents c'est à
dire un poids un état où elle oubliait
ses histoires de jardinage derosier dont
il parlait manière d'entretenir ses
rosiers elle pouvait oublier son corps
et et puis en même temps au sentire des
sensations différentes
c'était une manière au travers de la
conversation de faire un poids non pas
de la confusion mais de l'évocation et
de l'hypnose en ce qu'elle a de plus
simple quand on veut aider quelques
années alors pendant qu'il parlait de
ses rosiers dans sa manière de s'en
occuper pour que le rosier prennent de
la force de l'énergie de la présidence
il soulignait aussi qu'il fallait couper
ce que l'on appelle les les gourmands
c'est à dire des morceaux de rosiers qui
n'était pas bon qui pouvait créer une
sorte de douleurs de fatigue pour tous
le rosier donc suffisait de couper avec
un sécateur les gourmands et de laisser
tomber à terre ce morceau de douleurs
complètement inutile et que c'était
finalement on gérant cette douleur en la
laissant partir et en progressant se
développant finalement en faisant comme
une sorte de deux tailles utile à la
plante que celle ci pouvait prospérer et
parvenir à grandir et à se développer
et alors que jamais personne en face de
lui en en écoutant ses mots ses
suggestions autour d'une douleur qui
tombe et disparaît comme un morceau
branche que l'on coupe au sécateur et et
qui tombe tout simplement dont on se
débarrasse simplement en écoutant cet
échange et en se laissant perdre
finalement dans l'ennui dans la
confusion des mots du temps on pouvait
sentir à la fois son corps l'eau en
toujours plus lourd et calmer ses terres
agréable qui l'inspirait cette fraîcheur
qui se diffuser en lui et lui permettait
de ressentir une énergie agréable en lui
douce et calme est lente et finalement
bien sûr au bout d'un moment ils
fermaient les yeux est entré en transe
ou bien même s'il ne fermez pas les yeux
c'était le début de la transe et des
changements et cette évocation
finalement comme une sorte de métaphore
dans la métaphore de la métaphore
permettait d'entrer en transe 2 alors
que vous pensez s'accroche et se
décroche alors que faire et ce faisant
se faire que plus esprit est occupé plus
le corps est oubliée alors même que les
pensées s'accroche se décroche que faire
ce faisant se faire naître rien d'autre
que ce que l'on s'est fait un
il est temps de fermer les yeux s'il ne
l'était pas déjà et tout laissait encore
davantage portés par ma voix qui va bien
créer un et des boutiques de plus en
plus profond qui va engourdir en quelque
sorte le corps pour libérer l'esprit et
l'imagination libérer la pensée
inconsciente et les pensées plaisante la
rêverie et c'est dans cet ensemble
finalement entre les pensée consciente
les pensées inconsciente ce qui fait que
lorsqu'on est captivé par une discussion
on oublie tout jusqu'au temps jusqu'au
corps jusqu aux inquiétudes qui s'efface
et disparaissent littéralement comme
s'ils disparaissaient dans une sorte de
fumer comme ça on est dans un rêve on y
prie pas la conversation on est pris par
un épisode qu'on regarde à la télé de sa
série préférée
et même quand c'est au contraire l'ennui
ou la confusion qui règne dans non pas
l'expression simple peut-être la manière
de parler
de la personne qui vous accompagne eh
bien on se met aussi à sortir en quelque
sorte de son corps pour le plus être là
parfois si on a un peu mal à l'aise on
s'écarte un tout petit peu du corps et
puis parfois on va encore plus loin cela
devient agréable parce que on s'enfonce
dans une rêverie un rêve qui n'a rien à
envier au rêve du sommeil qui est un
rêve doux et agréable et qui appartient
à chacun qui fait que l'on a tendance à
entrer en transe davantage et c'est donc
mélange dépenser un peu comme vous voyez
des pas qui s'imprime ray sur la plage
sur le sable et qui fera mesure serait
de plus en plus effacée par les vagues
pour disparaître comme un endroit que
l'on aimerait plus peuplés d'inquiétude
et de souffrance et que l'on verrait
disparaître au loin lorsque l'on est
dans un train et que l'on se dirige vers
un pays vers un voyage agréable nous
pouvons déjà ressentir les promesses
d'un ailleurs des plages plaisant des
montagnes merveilleuse et c'est parfois
simplement avec la fraîcheur de l'air
qu'on inspire sa manière de se diffuser
dans tout le corps et de répandre à la
fois fraîcheur à l'engourdissement on
peut se demander à quel endroit le corps
est déjà le plus engourdie est-ce que
c'est au niveau des yeux est ce que ce
niveau des mains des gens de la
respiration
d'où vient cet engourdissement qui a son
rythme calme et lourd permet aux muscles
de se détendre et de peser davantage
tous apporté par l'hypnose et ma voix et
la respiration toujours plus lent
ce qui donne une sorte d'immobilité plus
grande au corps et c'est pour ça qu'au
fur et à mesure votre corps peut devenir
plus lourd vraiment plus lourd
simplement en abandonnant le corps en
laissons la volonté est bien migrer les
rêves et penser on laisse les bras très
très lourd les jambes lourdes le corps
lourd et alors que chaque respiration
pas mais au contraire à l'esprit de
s'alléger de commencer à rêvasser à des
choses agréables très légère très légère
peut-être des vocations de voyage ou d'
aventure peut-être d île merveilleuse
quelque part peut-être la vision d'un
lac très paisible peut-être d'autres
choses qui pour vous sont les vocations
à la fois du bonheur et de la légèreté
de la vie peut-être une balade en forêt
peut-être tout autre chaussée à votre
inconscient de laisser sa rêverie
s'installer le corps lui alors déserté
par l'esprit au contraire s'alourdit
dans une immobilité calme est lente et
dont le poids est renforcée par le
relâchement musculaire le corps est
lourd tellement lourd que l'on sent
d'autant plus son poids qui s'imprime
comme ça sur le lit
très lourde car le corps bien lourd bien
qu est ce qui fait qu'au bout d'un
moment c'est un peu comme si ce qui
reste de douleur devenait plus lourd
vraiment lourd et pouvait commencer à
acquitter tout en lourdeur le corps
comme des sortes de gouttes de lourdeur
qui pressés par le poids encore plus
lourd dit par le corps de plus en plus
calme tranquille et l'esprit alléger le
douleur s'écoule du corps peut-être à
tous les niveaux du corps peut-être
juste au niveau des pieds ou des mains
du visage
elle tombe cette douleur comptes a good
très lourdement
elle traverse le matelas à travers ce le
salle puis bientôt les fondations de
cette maison de cet immeuble est allé
encore plus loin dans le centre de la
terre jusqu'à l'endroit où les lave le
magma en fusion
toute la chaleur du noyau de la terre de
ses couches inférieures
va brûler sa douleur la laisser partir
ou peut-être devenir quelque chose
d'autre parce que pendant que lourdeur
de cette souffrance est cool de plus en
plus lourde et calme en dehors de vous
l'esprit lui voyage de plus en plus vous
pouvez imaginer ressentir cet endroit
vous avez déjà commencé à rêver qui va
pouvoir se préciser et finalement trouvé
l'expérience le paysage qu'il vous faut
un paysage presque hypnotique un paysage
fait pour la contemplation un paysage de
sécurité et vous savez qu'à chaque fois
que vous laisserez votre respiration se
ralentir
eh bien vous pourrez en fermant les yeux
retrouver ce lieu de sécurité hors du
stress hors de la douleur lieu de
bien-être général
et pour le corps lourd est pour l'esprit
léger
à chaque fois de plus en plus calmes et
pour créer comme une sorte d'encre pour
que vous retrouviez de plus en plus
facilement cet endroit vous allez
d'abord imaginé ce qui reste de stress
ou de douleurs dans le corps sur le
forme sous la forme de taches rouges
plus ou moins foncée plus ou moins large
et vous aller serrer le poids et toutes
seront tous leurs ce stress fêtant lé
point se concentrer pour devenir presque
écarlate et vous relâchez le point et là
la douleur et les inquiétudes et le
stress s'en vont car même les pensées
peut disparaître reprenait encore une ou
deux fois cela que reste-t-il de rouge
dans le corps de douleurs de stress ou
de penser dans le cerveau de rumination
et puis fatigue et déjà le corps lourd
et l'esprit très léger contracté à
nouveau ce point contracté pour que tous
se précipitent tous résume tout se
concentre dans ce point
et vous là j'ai encore plus fatigué le
corps est encore plus long et l'esprit
encore plus légers parce que vous êtes
déjà ailleurs toujours dans ce paysage
agréable cet endroit
ce refuge cette sécurité une dernière
fois contracté contracter et vous
chez le point pour laisser ce qui
restait de tension disparaître et
maintenant c'est le temps du repos il
vous suffira de serre et le point de
fermer les yeux pour retrouver ce lieu
de sécurité se calme
c'est analgésie loin de tout le corps de
plus en plus confortable et l'esprit de
plus en plus loin il leur reste
maintenant à l'esprit le temps de la
contemplation contemplation hypnotique
ce paysage qui est fait pour vous par
vous ou plutôt à votre inconscient se
laisser porter par ce paysage se laisser
envahir par sa beauté sentir à chaque
fois que vous inspire et cette sensation
étonnante c'est comme si vous inspiriez
la beauté le cas la douceur de ce
paysage
et toute cette beauté se calme se répand
dans les poumons puis dans les bras les
jambes le visage et tout cela hélas au
corps cette envie de se laisser porter
comme ça de dériver vers un confort de
plus amples cale de plus en plus tous et
pour ceux qui souhaitent simplement
utiliser cette séance pour gérer leur
stress ou la douleur ils pourront
simplement compter de 1,5 et sortir de
transe mais pour les autres pour vous
rester avec moi a laissé encore
davantage ce paysage sa beauté son calme
sa pureté se répandre en vous laissez
vous porter d'une manière douce et calme
par ma voix et laissez vous bercer par
la plus belle des musiques celle de
votre propre respiration ballons dont le
rythme lanka mais régulier vous berce
comme un enfant bercé dans les bras de
ses parents peut se laisser porter sans
dormir se sentir rassurés en sécurité
mais respiration fait pour ça et le
corps le sait bien puisque il
s'abandonne haine et se laisse porter
par le lit par sa chaleur part n'avoir
pas le temps qui passe
c'est par cette manière d'être bercés
par sa respiration
si chaque silence maintenant aussi
devient un moment de calme de bien-être
intérieur dans tout le corps et aussi
dans l'esprit et c'est autour du corps
de découvrir de plus en plus cet
engourdissement d'où celui qu'apportent
la fatigue et le sommeil le corps peut
s'endormir à son rythme
où se trouve cette fatigue dans le corps
peut-être est-ce dans tout le corps
justement peut-être à certains endroits
et à mesure que la respiration bat la
mesure
cette mesure justement donne à ce repos
à cette fatigue
de plus en plus de place et elle se
répand vous le s'intensifier le corps et
loup et les paupières sont de plus en
plus lourde et même l'esprit de plus en
plus souvent décroche oublie d'oublier
d'oublier dans ce que déjà un tableau
noir que l'on efface des vocations de la
lourdeur et de l'air frais calme et des
muscles qui se détendent dans cette
évocation si d'un endroit protecteur et
d'une rêverie tous qui s'installe comme
si l'esprit pouvait voguer ou bien
planer découvrir de nouveaux endroits de
nouveaux lieux de nouveaux paysages
encore lui le droit de la douceur de la
torpeur du can de la récupération du
soleil n'est alors que ma voix devient
de plus en plus ou de moins en moins un
peu importe dans sa présence ou son
absence quand son recul comme un arrière
fond en tout cas une évocation presque
une musique celle douce et cannes qui
nous permette de glisse
dérivé volter ou plutôt plein est vers
quelque chose d'autre
aux frontières entre l'inconscient et le
sommeil entre le sommeil hypnotique le
sommeil de la nuit un moment oublier de
penser
oubliez tous blessés
presqu'à terme en les yeux se fermer à
nouveau comme pour partir vers autre
chose se laisser porter enfin par le
repos de la nuit
et cette sensation du contact de l'air
vrai contre le visage et du corps chaud
ce contraste agréable entre la douceur
de l'air frais qui se diffuse dans le
corps et le corps était chaud et détendu
et calme et lourd qui s'endort de plus
en plus et dans les pensées inconsciente
très consciente en tout cas où même
plutôt l'absence de pensée juste une
sensation d images fugaces
en tout cas le moment où la pensée
arrête de penser l'oreille arrêt dégoûté
le corps tout engourdi de sommeil de
calme s'endort complètement oublié la
place tout ce que vend déjà on pouvait
oublier de ne plus se souvenir de
laisser partir t'oublier comme je vous
le dis car dans ce qui nous est cher on
ce que nous pouvons ne plus nous
rappeler laissé à douceur de
l'effacement et de l'oubli et le calme
de leur respiration
il est temps pour al
de se faire plus lente pour frais au
corps
une lenteur douce plaisante cas
qui emporte loin très loin vers le
sommeil finalement au bout d'un moment
il n'a plus de mots n'a plus de sens
juste une respiration lente un corps qui
s'endort et des mots vides de sens mais
rempli d'une sorte de rythme lent ne
musique douce elle de la nuit celle de
lee pelouse alors lentement on
s'abandonne à la détente et au sommet et
on oublie tout jusqu'à l'obscurité 12 de
la nuit jusqu'à chaleur douce du lit
jusqu'à la respiration régulière et
l'esprit vide parce que rempli de ses
rêves qui s'installe de plus en plus est
l'hypnose ou rêves de la nuit
qui sait c'est pour cela tout simplement
on se calme tranquille d'une nuit passée
dans ce recul tant ce pas de côté dans
cette dérive tout
dans cette manière de glisser ailleurs
de planer en tout cas de se laisser
alourdi dans la fatigue aidant le
sommeil vous dormez fauteurs mais vos
dormait
sept séances de bien-être vous a été
proposé en partenariat avec fit aux
nuits fit aux nuits en sachet à infuser
un mélange innovant de mélatonine
l'hormone naturelle du sommeil et de
cinq plants pour s'endormir et bien
dormir
bonne nuit avec le complément
alimentaire vide aux nuits